right every woman will tell you that on
the subway in New York City every single
one there's always a guy who's like
whoops it's crowded in here
yawns oh sorry I gotta put my push my
dog bed oh I'm brushing your teeth as
texture oh I'm mixing this texture I
take stroking this yesterday there's
just guy who I see in the gym hopeful
and he's homeless oh hopefully well if
he doesn't pop cash out to this guy he's
crazy
I've seen a lot of freaks in my lifetime
through sports
I never seen someone like this French
homeless guy I catch him the gym once
every three months the ED visit Bachmann
he's just in the weight room and he
comes in he lifts in jeans and a sweat
and a rolled-up cutoff sweatshirt like
he's from [ __ ] pump and I are sure
Arnold serial killer mitten long hair
French and just he's [ __ ] Jack bright
doesn't eat many meals but just genetics
and he talks himself in a hole here's
this French accent so makes even
creepier and he's so goddamn strong and
I would just stare at him actually
wanted one of those he's crazy strong I
want one of the things he was using when
the these things do these Paulette so I
was too scared to ask him he's gonna
bite me rip my face off but he gets on
the bench and he goes oh yes yes yes oui
oui oui oui all you want you want to
start you want to stop no no unit stop
you not stop wait burn now it burning it
burned there why you stop you ain't
stopping you stop it
you have 20 more you have 20 more you
have to start yes yes yes yes thing
drops it in he'll go this is what you
want to do is what you want to do you
hear just what you want to do you do
this gets a friend who do it if you want
to do this he's talking about he goes
yeah and they look but it's like he's
just in there by himself
yeah let her go this go heavier we gonna
have for you you wanna go ahead he's
having this conversation with himself
and he goes what's he happiest you live
have you grabs the Bible know where he
found them cuz I'm always looking for
heavier weights
goes those and goes now and then he'll
do that and then went to cable and I
mean while I pretend I'm working out but
I have my headstone course not working
just listen to do just cuz it gives and
then he also has his entire
with him in a in a rollaway bag oh yeah
well yeah he's obviously not all there
he gets on the crossover machine he's
gone
hey he's crazy strong though stupid
strong really weights stronger than me
what waist Ron it's very dangerous
no diet and up.just why really gets done
and goes yes yes big big a big giant huh
yeah he looks like Shankar and I had a
baby and friends well that's very
Spartan cute guys that but not like
breaded just like he looks like the
juggernaut from x-men but French is [ __ ]
there's a Pancrase event in Japan and
this guy who's weighing in he his team
had to carry him onto the scale
I'll show you a little bit of it but
basically he's basically dead on his
feet and then oh [ __ ]
so he wasn't able to make the first one
cuz they're carrying him essentially he
should not be fighting no oh Lord
they couldn't wait a minute at that time
so he came back and they actually had
him where he was balancing on his own
for just a second is he falling asleep
he's weak is how my god and they go they
give him a thumbs up like all right he
weighed in and they have to carry him
offstage look how bad this nice yes
that's the worst way and I've ever seen
yeah
and they let him fight I don't know if
he fought yet but it looks like you lost
like Jesus Christ
oh it's sickening
yeah I don't know the Commission's you
know they let Kevin Lee fight with staff
they're just it's a businessman it's
unfortunate New York doesn't play that
[ __ ] though
bring that dude up in New York and he
ain't making anything I don't think he
would have made it anywhere else other
than I don't think so yeah you never
know biggest pretty tricky meaning they
don't give a [ __ ] but you never know
they New York not happening California
there's 300 episode and this reminds me
but how many have we done though be
think how many did we do on our own with
a mic in your in your I mean I've got
she weaves probably done 500 episodes
that's what I'm thinking right five
hundo well we did we were doing well
into well over a year before we get went
to Fox I think that Lee's yeah year and
a half yeah you know so long time in a
long time I've known you a long time and
I wish I could sing a song about you you
don't sing anymore god oh you got a fool
now told you stop singing cuz your
brains off [ __ ] that noise about me used
to be so much more fun when you were
younger in person getting old and
rickety and your teeth bother me the
[ __ ] out of me I was supposed to wear my
tres to dine today and I forgot them in
my kitchen set my wife a text and I
forgot my trays boring boring I need
metal braces what metal braces